so we want to think about what goes into
writing a close reading paper you know
there's two words that are reading and
writing they're connected with each
other in this kind of assignment and
there's been a lot of you know questions
and confusions about exactly you know
how to do this sort of thing yeah like I
put in the assignment sheet this isn't
something that you've been introduced to
for the most part in your high school
and probably not you know in a lot of
their college classes and talking with
some of you are interacting with you
through through email or messaging it's
become apparent to me that some of the
ways of writing that people have taught
you particularly in high school are
actually a bit counterproductive they
told you things about writing that maybe
they presented us as being you know this
applies in every case and you learned it
because you're good students but now
it's actually going to be an impediment
you know for example all the talks about
this a little bit before can you use the
word a tie in writing philosophy papers
that's a good question yeah so you can
use the word hi and there's certain
context in which you would use that in
other contexts in which you wouldn't but
somewhere along the line apparently in
high school middle school a lot of
people are teaching students don't use I
and why would they teach that sort of
thing because it seems very subjective
and lends itself to people just you know
making a lot of my statements but it's
good to do it sometimes and with a pulse
reading paper you are the reader it's
your reading that that's going on so the
word I is perfectly appropriate it's
things like that that made me think yeah
maybe we could use a little bit of
structures I'm gonna walk through a
closer reading this workshop is going to
be mostly about right because that's the
stage that you guys are currently and I
changed the assignment deed for the
close reading paper and a lot of you
work on it so far but if you if you want
to do anything else on it there's plenty
of time for that after this workshop so
let's talk about what close reading is
to start with this term closes is really
important
you're it's a way of approaching a task
very attentively looking at all of its
features
taking it in think about when you
actually think about this think about
when you not just like somebody but
really like them like you're attracted
to them and now you want to know
everything about them all right if
you've all experienced that sort of
thing and you look at their face and you
never noticed the way their nose you
know goes here you know close their eyes
are and how they sparkle and all that
kind of stuff you guys are all familiar
with that right well experience that
that's a sort of attentiveness to detail
attentiveness to structure attempted
Ness you watch the way that they want
you know that's kept silly but something
like that can be applied to tasks and
every one of you has some things it may
not actually be texts that are written
but every one of you has some sort of
narrative some sort of sawing some sort
of thing that has the invades meaning
that you have paid that much attention
to in the past and I'm not saying you
have to pay that much attention Plato
where Augustine in this close reading
paper I'm just saying it's along those
sort of lines that kind of attentiveness
so a close reading involves is back and
forth process reading powerful breathing
right yeah reading some more and writing
some more and what should be going on in
the middle of it where do you fit in I
mean you're doing some reading and
you're doing writing so here's you know
process here's a product you think in
this interplay between the reading and
the writing and what are you reading
you're reading somebody else's thoughts
better written and what are you
alternately producing something that
actually conveys your own thoughts write
your own way of reinterpreting what it
is so they were talking that's what
makes it a close reading of Plato or
Aristotle or of Cicero or of the
Augustine you were taking somebody
else's thoughts and in a way you're
digesting them and making them your own
and the way that you're doing that does
involve the processes of paying
attention while you're reading and
you'll find that if you do some of the
writing in parts these things will sort
of reinforce each other you never get
everything out of the first reading or
the second reading or even though the
30th we you never get everything that's
in these classic texts that's why
they're classic text that's why we keep
going back to a lot of other books
turned out you know you can get
everything you need out of them the
first time you read through them so once
you've done that throw it away you don't
need to read it if you actually become
interested in what's going on in Plato
you've got to keep reading him over and
over and over again it's like a sickness
okay gets his hooks in or an addiction I
don't mean put it in such terms but it
is you know analogous to that there's a
wider context
which is part of why I'm bringing it up
not all of you are going into
disciplines in the humanities right some
of you are the sciences someone of
you're going to be in the social
sciences education business we have
passion here ended Maris which is
actually a very rigorous discipline but
I actually have a lot of respect for
because I know how much work they have
to do in the humanities close reading is
something that we do quite a bit and why
do we do it because we get certain
things out of it and we'll talk about
that in a moment one of the reasons I'm
bringing this up is that if we're doing
this in an English class close reading
and paying attention to the text would
probably mean paying attention to the
language you know how does it sound
what are characters doing over and over
again how does the plot developing those
sort of things you know things you did
in book reports you guys remember you
stuff to do book reports in and you know
K through 12 read a book what's the
theme what's the plot what are the
characters that kind of stuff okay but
also that's good that you do that
because you're paying attention you're
beginning a close reading that you're
actually paying attention to what's
going on in that text why did other
people tell me I should I should read
this text there's got to be something
there what is when you start looking at
portions of it that details of it you
start making connections part of the
pulse reading is paying attention not
just to you know each little hurt by
itself and then saying okay I'm done
it's thinking back and forth within the
text you know a close reader will
actually page back and forth wait a
second he said this here what's that
and look here that's part of the process
of reading and you probably did that
when you were reading you know actually
did this even before you worried about a
close reading assignment right because
when you're reading Cicero you probably
had to say what hell is this what's he
talking about here then you paged back a
little bit and they said oh I get it
where you said I'm still confused and
you know it's okay to be confused being
confused is the natural way in which we
approach great literature and a lot of
people act as if you should open the
book and it's just a book you know like
the meanings should just pop out it all
right you feel that way sometimes you
put yourself into that camp pressure
these are hard books these are hard
works of literature and it takes a lot
of time and work to get the meaning out
of it and it's okay for you to struggle
it's okay for you to have to work
there's nothing wrong with you on that
account
you know the book can change you in the
process if you're working on that's why
people have kept out using them in
education in philosophy what are we
really paying attention to for close
reading we're really paying attention to
a couple different things one is
concepts ideas you know like for example
plato's doctrine of recollection I think
cite now at this point in the semester
all of you to give me a little thumbnail
sketch it might not be perfect but you
could give me some sort of sketch about
what this you know these words doctor of
recollection and if I asked you show me
in the two platonic texts that we looked
at where is he talking about this you
could probably point to certain passages
couldn't you that's a skill you've now
acquired a certain skill with a certain
concept if you wanted to know more about
it you'd probably read around in that in
those two attacks or maybe reads
to get a better idea of what he's
talking about
well sorry interested arguments
philosophy is in large part about
arguments and arguments are saying you
know here's what I think here's why I
think that I don't think the soul
survives after death you know that's a
claim right remember some people made
better than in the Phaedo why well
because this whole maybe is kind of like
a harmony you know parts of the body and
that you know if you look at other
things that have a harmony
now that you've actually got an argument
you've got a claim and you've got all
these other things that are supposed to
be leading you to that claim that's part
of what you're looking for in these
texts and I think many of you probably
either wrote your close reading paper on
an argument or an argument fits into
your close reading paper in some way or
another right we're also looking at how
these different these different things
are connected with each other and one
other thing that goes into a
philosophical close reading sometimes is
paying attention to why people change
their minds we don't have a awful lot of
that in these dialogues but we do have
some places where say a student is
confused and by the time they get done
with it there
we also have somewhere if somebody
started off thinking they knew exactly
what they're talking about and by the
time the dialogue is over they they're
like I'm talking about I know I'm not
right about this but I don't remember I
don't know you know what it was that I
thought I'd get about verges like who
who said that remember say yeah
exactly you know you know he starts out
thinking that he knows something and
then after a while Socrates ask just
he's just asking questions right he's
not really just asking questions they're
the right questions at the right time
then after a while he knows like man I
don't know what I'm talking about
that's actually the achievement and you
could chart that up that would be that
would be good fodder for a philosophical
reading why does somebody go from
thinking that they know about something
to realizing that they need to study
more they need to inquire or you know
somebody was worried about is you know
can God know everything ahead of time
and yet we have free will and we did
that a couple weeks ago by the time that
we get to the end of Augustine's
dialogue the students like yeah no I get
it
you can sure about that now I get it
you know now he gets it what is it that
he gets why does he how did he get to
that point that's doing both reading
you're you're being very attentive to
what is going on in the text and now
this is a process that can get you know
you can start out have a sort of
beginner level and get to an
intermediate level to an advanced level
we're working out of here stuff that's
mostly at the beginner level that
already is kind of demanding right and
there's nothing wrong with being a
beginner you have to be a beginner
before you can get to the intermediary
level but this is sort of the basic
structure that you're going to be
following suit all the time now you guys
are mostly
right so that's mostly what I'm going to
focus on one other thing that I want to
get on before we start getting into nuts
and bolts and that's thinking about
reasons purposes if you understand why
you're doing an assignment I think that
helps you know clear away some of the
worries the concerns about whether
you're getting it right doesn't it
and also you know helps to get rid of
the frustration that sometimes you feel
like why in the hell did he assign this
crap to me you know this is this is not
why do I have to do this right well it
helps you deal with that which is you
know that that's something that gets in
your way as a student so we do want to
be a little clearer in our way so what
are the reasons why somebody might do a
culture very great right who is that
motivating in this class every pitch
eraser because you all right that's
important to you guys
that's what can I understand why else
should you do maybe some of you really
care about what I think about you do a
good close reading you'll impress me you
know that's fine you know I like
students enjoy seeing you guys
progressed but you don't actually you
don't have to make me happier you know
make me think any particular man if you
do that that's that's sort of like gravy
but two semesters from now how's that
gonna matter
grades Alijah to stick around a little
while all right please leave me
why else what else okay so now that's a
good that's a good purpose yeah these
texts it's sort of like a promise if you
put in the work that you'll get
something out otherwise there's no point
assigning you these guys you know we've
got something that will be assigned and
then students say I never get anything
out of this we should throw that book
away library is you know full of good
books and that's also for garbage books
that we don't actually need we have way
more stuff being written than we
possibly need the text that we're
assigning you there's valuable stuff in
there for you as who you are and who
you're going to be that you know you've
got to work to understand if you want to
have that as a possession for yourself
what else that's important again
yeah that's a little bit different than
gaining the particular whatever it is
the knowledge the understanding that
you're getting out of that particular
test right that's a broader skill that's
something that you can take with you
into your career into any further you
know study that you're going to do you
can apply these techniques if you
actually think about this you can apply
this to things other than books and
that's a high level skill that you want
to be able to transfer from this to
other places you can only do that if you
develop that skill what else about the
great what am I actually grading you on
writing a certain amount that really
understanding and what you say yeah it's
got a lot of grammatical errors that can
that can lower the rate of the paper
yes knowledge
yeah you're only gaining knowledge I
also want you to be able to articulate
the other reason why you might be closer
if you were at some you know very
weighty tweety elite college you know
where you're part of the culture
industry or something like that maybe if
you want to learn to do a closer reading
so you can impress all your peers and
show your parents that you're actually
learning something in school or stuff
like that but those are all sort of like
in they're gonna call attendance
extrinsic they're not they're not things
that are necessarily tied to that I mean
if you were not in college could you
still do close readings you wouldn't be
getting grade you might do them on your
own there maybe there's ability of
reading it that you actually please or
impress or anything but you could be
doing these things right I have to part
of the reason I want you to articulate
or demonstrate your knowledge
understanding is because I do have read
on something and if I'm going to grade
you on something and it's probably
better but it'd be something real rather
than just something that we call proxy
so I'm asking you to do something real
here but it has to do with this gaining
understanding of the text and this skill
and the way I'm going to measure you is
as beginners you know there's a
lower-level class is your first
introduction
kind of thing so I'm not expecting that
you do you know the kind of high level
work that somebody who's a philosophy
major has had eight classes in
philosophy is able to do at this point I
just want you to be able to sort of
throw yourself into this and do as much
as you can think of it like you know gym
class when they made you do these tests
and just try your best
all right if you do that you'll actually
start getting a lot out of this so now
let's actually talk about nuts and bolts
what let's talk about the process itself
I put up that diagram of you know going
back and forth between reading and
writing what's what's involved first
thing you got to do is decide on the
complex all right and all of you I think
have a topic don't you
everybody has anybody who doesn't have a
topic at this point who's so totally
lost that they they didn't come up with
something that they want to work out now
how did you think about about this topic
this is a big question how broad should
be so one of the things I want to say
from the beginning is it's not your job
and a close reading paper to try to
summarize the entire past or even just a
chapter of the test it's different than
something like a review the chapter
review you're looking for some
particular concept or a distinction or
argument or claim or development that
you think is interesting so did all of
you pick something that you found
interesting yes
did any of you pick something you didn't
find interesting if you did that's okay
but it's harder to write out something
you don't care about this
how hard did you have to look to find
something that was interesting for you
yeah the thing that I actually picked
out was there's something I know is in
overall the reading of sister Maitre D'
yeah my
topic with really just how malaise and
how about all they do is discredit each
other they don't really stay an actual
argument except for at the end of the
latest ya little rant but the only one
throughout the entire unit all of us who
actually comes out made statements and
doesn't really discredit anyone else so
I guess I just look back that's an
interesting topic that's a little bit
different than like just focusing on an
argument or a concept that's out a
little bit of a higher level you're
looking at what's going on within the
text and you can do that with other
times it's in like why is Socrates
seemingly such a jerk you know that
could be a that could be a viable topic
by the end hopefully you figure out
who's not sure right but you could start
out with something like that what you
know a lot of people ask do I need to
have a thesis statement you don't
actually do the thesis statement what
are you doing they're educated and you
don't actually have to have a thesis per
se at the start
what you need is is a question or an
interest or something that puzzles you
and you could be you know you can be
reading a dialogue and you know you're
reading Augustine and the students
something you're like yeah what about
that Augustine go by this this this all
fits together somehow that doesn't make
sense that's okay that's a good starting
point for you that's part of the process
that's the beginning of the process and
then then what do you do you start
reading the text and you're gonna have
to read the text multiple times to pay
close attention to what's going on in
the text and you're oriented by your
interest or your question that you're
you're focusing us you probably want to
take a lot of notes while you're doing
this do a lot of underlining when you
see the same language coming
over and over again pay attention to
that you know in Augustine the word will
she was coming up right
you could read but Augustine's notion of
the will that would be a viable pulse
reading topic and you would want to go
through and like you know start to
parable is he talking about it the same
way here as he is here and now that
you're not even you know necessarily
after the writing part you're not
actually writing the paper per se but
you're doing some writing right did your
jotting these things down and you start
out doing it sort of a lower level arrow
it's more and more more and more
involved you know this isn't the kind of
paper that you're gonna write at the
last minute before it's due because the
process itself is a process of study and
then writing and taking notes there's
different strategies that you can use
there's no one-size-fits-all way of
doing this some of you are better note
takers some of you like to underline in
the text some of you would like to make
charts and diagrams right do whatever
works for you and you know use and try
out other strategies if you see a
roommate
something that's useful for for them I
should try that if it works for you
that's good you have to be very
pragmatic about this key and whether it
helps you think about the tax and
thinking is hard thinking as you know
makes your head hurt sometimes right
that's okay again your job in this whole
process is to develop a certain level of
expertise you don't want to just
understand things at a surface level you
want to understand you know what what
separates the expert from somebody who's
read Wikipedia and memorized Wikipedia
the expert understands what the expert
can tell you why something is being done
a certain way when you're writing this
sort of stuff that that term why should
be coming up for you over and over again
because you're going to actually apply
that to your own stuff now that's what's
going to talk about the product what are
you actually going to turn in there's
some formal requirements yeah you know I
mean those could vary from teacher to
teacher to teacher
I don't really care much about
documentation because I'm not really
that interested in this this particular
paper using outside sources if you do
use outside sources I think you know I
got to make you document them because
that's part of what we do here in
college but I'm not a huge stickler
about that some teachers are really
really into that right I think you've
had some and they seem more into that
and then the content that you're writing
I'm also not a grammar police person you
know I want to figure out what you're
saying
I don't want have to struggle with the
grammar but I don't really care that
much about it compared to you know what
you're actually showing me but you
understand I've got students
very important grammar that words were
very smart and very intelligent things
to say if they said you know some
trouble articulating involves grammar is
it school writing to minimum life here's
another thing I want to say about that
usually instructors will say you know I
need this moment work right what's the
minimum length for these very short
close readings three to three full pages
yes now if your strategy is to write to
get to three full pages that's generally
a losing strategy you write to the
length that that your thought requires
and if you're you're getting if you're
you know writing stuff and you only have
two an amp pages then not enough
thinking is going into it because with
any of these philosophical topics but if
you're actually doing this process of
going back and forth you know reading
writing thinking about what you're doing
you're going to write more than three
pages this is pretty pretty easily
some of you actually may find yourself
feeling self-conscious because you end
up writing quite a bit then you're like
man this guy's gonna you know downgrade
me because I wrote too much I know I
don't do that I just don't want you to
write like a 20-page paper for this
because you know it's only worth 30
points yeah I want you to do well then
you grab the fastest is that I want you
to take away from from your other
classes for this but you know if you
right before pages that's fine if you
write five pages that's fine
it all depends on what the thought
requires you let the thought rot in the
show you let you let the the reading and
the writing we're on the show rather
than trying to write just to get to
three pages and you won't have any
trouble get into three pages in part
because what you're gonna be doing by
going through multiple steps it's
looking at your own writing and saying
what could I add here what else needs
that and when you do that you're going
to find that your writing just kind of
like grows like like a bush you know no
bush like the certain size with a couple
little branches and then branches come
off of those branches
or can one with balls in pretty soon
takes up half the yard that's the way
these sort of projects and this will be
useful for you another other classes
what are you trying to do what's the
bigger picture one way to figure that
out is by looking at that that great
right that tells you the standards that
I'm using to measure your performance
but yeah oh sorry
actually that's okay here we go yeah you
know it's got several categories and you
notice there's points nose the writing
mechanics less points than the other
things cuz I'm not that worried about
your spelling and grammar the more
interested in things like understanding
of main concepts right or understanding
Hosmer's position interpreting authors
text organization those sorts of things
those are you might say dimensions of
your paper and it's worth thinking about
that the further you get along in the
writing process you know more you're
close to the closer you are to be having
a final draft the more you're gonna pay
attention to it so that sort of stuff
but part of what you want to look at is
on the assignment sheet when I say you
know what do you really have to do in
your close reading you know there's what
you have to do this steps by format
requirements but then there's the what
are you doing in order to carry this out
you do this like I said by by selecting
some sort of central idea or claim or
argument or a problem or you know
development and you try to explain it as
fully and comprehensively as possible to
to me you know or to anybody else and
also to yourself to a certain extent
you're gonna learn things along the way
you're gonna write things
my hand anymore right but you're gonna
write things and then you're gonna have
moments where you say oh wait a second
now I actually understand this after
you've written about it and then I
wonder why it's called a close reading
like I said you should approach each
text but you're studying with this this
guiding assumption that there's a lot
there that if if it doesn't make
complete sense to you yet that there's
more thinking and more rereading to do
more notation and you know you may
arrive at the point where it's still
ultimately doesn't make sense to you but
if you can articulate why it doesn't
make sense to you why things don't add
up that's a good close reading that
makes that a little counterintuitive but
that's actually the case so how do you
how do you carry this out I've got like
the whole process here you know about
prewriting and planning reading and
writing writing multiple drafts many of
you have already turned in something so
that's your rough draft now if you want
to go a little bit further with them or
improve it in any way up to edges if
this workshop helps you out to give you
you know some other and he is about
where to look now you've got a rough
draft that you can actually escape and
you can you know go back to the Texas
state and I get this right is there more
to be said here and you can improve your
draft students writing is always
actually a professor writing to is
always improvable none of us ever read
perfect peace and remember what is your
writing things your thought that's why
it's valuable because your thought is
you know what it's not just for a grade
it's for you were developed yeah I think
that's probably enough of that about a
process if you guys have any questions
at this before like I'm doing yeah
components like understanding the other
points that the author makes
understanding how they're tied in to you
know the point that you're focusing on
yeah should we really like tune in on
like one point and then like study those
other things in relation to it or if
it's a good question yeah there should
be some central focus to your paper and
then and you don't have to try to
address everything that the author is
talking about oh yeah you don't want
this to try to be like a chapter with
you or something like that if there are
other relevant things that the author is
saying or you know the dialogue the
other characters were saying then you
can bring that in and you want to in a
way to think about this is sort of like
being fair right you're gonna you're
gonna give your main point most of the
attention because that's your main point
yeah you think that's the most important
these other things they get to say a
little bit and so long as you let them
to have their their stay here you're
doing a good job if you tell them that
you're not going to say and then you
know it's also okay here's another thing
you can say well you know somebody else
might say this point over here is
relevant to this but I don't think so
here's why I don't think so you know
that demonstrates is a higher level of
thinking you know when you can not just
say why something is right or valuable
but why other things aren't as valuable
right you're really demonstrating the
high level sophisticated level thinking
and reading any other drug questions yet
one thing that became steadily conflict
was ended up paraphrasing the actual
like writing that I was working on a lot
so I kept putting citations like oh I
got this from here but it almost looks
like since I paraphrasing so much I'm
going to reading yeah there's little oh
my thought but it's mixed in that's okay
are you worried about whether by
documenting it you're sort of like
smuggling your own thought in and
pretending like your thought is as
important as Plato is or Cicero's or
something like that don't worry we don't
have to be worried about that it's just
more along lines of the distinction
between paraphrasing writing in such a
way where the paraphrase is integrated
with your own thought and straight up
corner straight up chorus is easy that's
a good good so actually
eh you are not just putting it into your
own words
it's the author's thoughts in your own
that's what makes a paradism
right you're not really contributing
anything like paraphrase is reframing it
so it might actually make sense to do
that if you were to you know it explains
things in a certain context like you
know you go home and break and
your little brother or sister he asked -
about this play-doh gang because they've
heard about them and you say well here's
what played upset and you see me doing
this a lot in class I'll say he was
saying this and I'll like frame in the
kind of you know lowered more
commonplace way of talking about it
rather than the elevated Oxfordian
translation that we have because we
don't talk that way right
that's paraphrasing I'm not actually
adding anything in my own to that other
than maybe choosing some you know
exciting language and then quotation is
just a horse but when you're
interpreting you are sort of like you
saying mixing or integrating rocket
sauce with your home and that's okay as
a matter of fact that's a good thing to
be able to do now the question is do you
have to document that is that what the
the concern is or to an agreement okay
they can't hurt you parts of this may be
in fact paraphrase or you might actually
like you only have a little snippets of
quotation in there that that you can
document you don't necessarily need to
document everything and there's some
things that are like so basic like Plato
had the theory of the forms you don't
need a document that because it's common
knowledge right we don't have a theory
of forms which is difficult for an
undergraduate student
they're hetero that's you actually
carrying out some interpretation right
because I don't know too many people
that are writing and telling us about
undergraduate students and Plato I'm
sure there's somebody out there doing it
but I haven't read them and Plato sure
isn't telling us about undergraduate
students or Aztecs doesn't even
interpret you know javis introduction or
something like that ciao it's not
actually talking about that either so
yeah I think it's okay and I highly
encourage you to be carrying out
interpretation I just want you to do the
judiciously as a matter of fact again it
shows a high level of sophistication you
can take it authors flaw and reframe it
in your own words and tie it in with
your own thoughts as well that's part of
what we do as professors you know I've
been in close reading for you guys up
here and the lecture one of the things
that I want to address I think is really
important and here I want a lot of you
know questions or things you you learned
about writing that are worrying you
about this paper so you know her all
right how many of you learn that you're
not supposed to use the word I wow
that's a lot and when I asked about this
I found out it's not just in high school
but also even some college writing
classes they shouldn't have taught you
that as a rule that's supposed to apply
across the board all the time
why not because it doesn't apply across
the board when should you use the word
up
yeah it makes perfect sense you know
what are you gonna do put it in third
person you know is you know or mr.
so-and-so believes that we're gonna talk
about yourself the way you know Marines
are taught to the third person that
would be really weird there are a few
people who do talk about themselves that
way in philosophy but they're really
excited people no way you should you
should feel free to use the word I you
don't need to use it all the time like
you don't need to say you also don't
have to go to the other the other
extreme of saying in my opinion you know
before everything you're making is a
claim because I know it's your opinion
because it's your paper right so you
don't have to use that as a
qualification but it's perfectly
appropriate certainly especially towards
the end for you to be saying I think
you're the one who wrote the paper
you're the one who put in the work
you're the one who's been doing the
reading and taking the notes presumably
you have something intelligent to say
about Plato of Cicero Arizona whoever
you're writing on because that's what
I'm looking for from you so it's okay to
use that language I want you to feel all
right about that but when you use the
word PI I want you to always keep this
that question why don't just tell people
I feel this way I think this way
give them a reason and a plausible
reason not just I feel this way because
I feel this way I feel this way because
you know play though I think is doing
something like this over here and that
strikes me as unfair it's okay to
criticize to so long as you can say why
that's that's the key thing what else
thesis states do you have to have a
thesis statement
this is one that actually a song if you
have some philosophy sites they they
like to have thesis statements or if
you're doing a close reading you don't
necessarily have to have a thesis
statement it's more important to be able
to identify what you're actually talking
about you don't necessarily have to
decide it here's exactly what Plato is
doing and he's right about this or is
wrong about this but you should be able
to articulate hey I'm going to write
about the theory of recollection and how
it shows up in the Meno of the fatal and
whether there's any difference as we do
the two of those so you don't need
something necessarily like a thesis
statement I've had students ask me
before it was do I have to write five
paragraphs you guys learn the five
paragraph essay throw all that stuff out
completely you don't need to think about
that you write as many paragraphs as the
writing needs and you don't have to do
you know the first paragraph does not
have to be some long thing about you
know in the beginning there was plate
over with them there was Aristotle or
anything like that like they you don't
do anything snazzy anything catchy
you're doing a scholarly paper here you
don't have to try to get our attention
at the beginning because we're not
writing copy for an advertisement you
know we're writing an essay for a
popular journal you're doing academic
writing at the end it's good to have a
conclusion where you do some things up
that that's helpful rather than just
ending with well that's all folks
something like that what else have you
guys been taught that that that when
you're writing this you're like yeah I'm
not sure if I need to apply this for
that what are other concerns yet
the backs of South oh come on we can
just base it off of your concern okay so
that's a good question
locations weird pneumatic thing there
you don't you don't necessarily need to
do that I mean it's good to be able to
point to places in the text that back up
your your reading of the text if you've
already given the you know if you've
already given that that material that
you're going to refer to anyway and now
you're gonna like actually say something
about it I think Plato's you know making
this point here you've already given up
you don't need to go back and pour it
again it is good to have you know some
sort of basis for what you're saying
that's that's the why it doesn't always
have to be a quotation part of what
you're doing in this is you're
establishing your own expertise
they say oh it's another good question
if you were working at a higher level
with this an intermediate or advanced
level then I would probably send you
over the library or actually do it on
your computer most likely so it's been
electronic everything and I would say I
want you to find what to other people
have had to say about your topic and
react to what they're saying yeah this
lovely you don't need to at this level
I'm content to have you just you know
grappling with Cicero over plate over
Augustine that's tough enough to begin
with
isn't it so you don't have to bring in a
secondary source yeah backs up we get it
backs up what you're saying or you're
reacting against something whether
whether I mean those two questions are
kind of related back yeah Oh what if we
were to like tie in another philosopher
and their ideas were leading to the
subject matter they could be consistent
with the one that we're studying that's
a good question too if you feel that
you've got a good enough background in
there then that that makes sense you
don't have to do that there's there's no
requirement again there you're starting
to get to a more intermediate
understanding and that might be
something you know especially if you
were like at that advanced level that
require you to you know talking about
Plato tell me about Aristotle too or you
know tell me about you know talking
about Plato's Socrates tell me about
Xenophon Socrates but this is an intro
level class no any other things you
you've heard or they drilled into you
that are worrying
writing as you're approaching these
things if you think of things like that
send them to me because I'd actually
like to make a list sometime things that
people are being taught that I want them
to unlearn so for my students for the
future you think of things like that
send them to me okay
let's look at the grading rubric now and
then what we're going to do actually
maybe I won't give you exchanged papers
with each other I'll just have you apply
this to your own paper let's look at
these different things notice there's
there's there's seven main things I'm
looking for in your papers that I need
agree and writing mechanics I'm not
going to talk much about that because
you know that's fairly straightforward
right framing the general issue you've
got tell me what this is about don't you
know don't assume though I don't think
it's gonna be a problem for an idiot but
don't assume that the reader
automatically knows exactly what you're
ready you you want to say what the issue
is and you also want to say what the
relevance is why somebody else would be
interested in this why this topic
matters and you know that may not be
apparent to you immediately so you want
to do a little thinking about that it
might often be helpful for you to talk
with another person about hey I've got
this paper I'm writing it does this does
that sound like an interesting topic to
you and they might say no that's not
super boring or they might say yeah
because I
about this kind of thing myself that
could go into your paper why it's
relevant to you as a person
why'd you pick that particular topic
that actually is part of its relevance
there's where the ice dates you know
could come in another why understand the
main concepts I'm looking for you to do
two things there one is that you show me
you understand the concepts that you're
working with if you're going to bring
something up you want to make sure that
you actually understand them I just want
you to know the connections between the
different concepts you see the
difference between those two things it's
one thing to treat each one separately
it's another thing and the higher levels
that they actually tie them together and
you know what to do is walk a lot of
work to title today tell me enough
sentence or two how these are they're
connected with each other understanding
the author's position I think this one's
pretty straightforward right if you're
telling me that Plato didn't believe in
the forms clearly that's right you tell
me that Augustine thought there was no
God or that God is evil okay there's
something went wrong in the reading
somewhere right but you want to show me
that you actually understand the
author's position how do you get to
understand the author's position there's
different ways right well it's gonna be
your main tool
yeah reading reading and rereading okay
is it okay to use outside sources to
understand the author can you go to an
internet encyclopedia of philosophy or
Stanford encyclopedia anyway the first
Wikipedia quite as much because it's
still not just
yeah those gonna be starting points
there's nothing we wrong with you
reading secondary sources I don't want
you to substitute that for your own
thinking there's nothing wrong with
using structure yes at the beginning I
want you to be able to you know show me
that you understand the author's
position and if the author is taking one
position that somebody else is taking a
different position so you know don't
confuse me know with Plato right who's
speaking for plaintiff of the dialogues
socrates right or you know his honesty
and a student are they the same person
obviously not cause one of them
Augustine hit that penitas with audience
so ammonia's may not actually be
speaking for Augustine
interpreting the author's text you want
to give some reasoning some some maybe
get an argument for why you're
interpreting the text the way that you
are mad again I'm not looking for
something terribly complex or super high
level which is something if you want to
do a better job with this you want to
look at other possible interpretations
you want to say why your interpretation
was the best one and that's this
beginner level you don't have to I would
say even if you just suggest one other
possible interpretation it's not like
you have to tell me everything that
anybody else would have ever thought
about Aristotle that would take you
forever right
on the aristotle without an aerosol
scholar because there's no way to sum up
everybody but you can tell me what what
one other possible interpretation and
why your interpretation is better why
your view on things makes more sense I'm
quoting or paraphrasing I do want you to
quote and paraphrase and there's kind of
an art to being able to pixels right
amounts here's one you don't pick like a
giant block and just like throw it out
there and say here you go
now you know we're all done you want to
break it up and actually in that
strategies for writing I give that to
you as one thing you want to think about
try not to quote more than say a line or
two at a time without in spurs
interspersing your own writing without
integrating it with your own your own
thought you want to pick you don't just
pick quotes at random - you want to pick
quotes that actually are germane to what
you're discussing that that are non
tract organization is another issue a
lot of times students struggle with this
quite a bit I actually struggled with it
myself because I think my thought is
more clear than it and it is even as a
writer now it's really important to have
somebody else will get your paper and
see whether all the parts fit together
whether they're connected with each
other whether the paper as a whole makes
any sense
now and then you know you've got these
other writing mechanics actually it
meant you know since we're a little bit
short on time we can do one of two
things we can either like you know spend
the rest of the time looking at your
your drafts thinking about these these
things in terms of the rubric or we can
talk about these different useful
strategies which would you like
yes yeah they ask you about the text as
well sure we could do that as well yeah
well I'm a [ __ ] about like how much of
an idea are you supposed to use like
what I used on um I use I'm freedom of
Augustine yeah yeah and liking what I
did was I ate best like where evil comes
from okay and whether or not God likes
your sports yeah and like the two sides
but like that's to the extent that I
discuss and like most of that was
covered in the beginning so I just
wasn't sure of like how much for the
topic or like how big it has to be
honest cooperate you know like how big
of an idea because like most of my
really focus on the beginning of his
okay that's that's a good good question
so you can narrow it by saying you know
what I'm really going to talk about is
God responsible for you yeah now you've
got a couple of different subtopics that
are connected to that did God create
evil no that answered that innovative of
one well you know maybe God's
responsible for it because he was you
know dumb enough to give us free will
and that was a bad move on his part
should have known better
that's talk more about in my book too
but it's only a portion of that's where
the I wish I hadn't erased the reading
or anything that's where that goes back
and forth while you're taking notes and
thinking about your topic you go back to
the text and said we're in the text
this actually being talked about their
moms where where do I we're going to put
down my my stakes you know and may not
may not be very much of the tax that's
okay again don't feel like you have to
summarize everything and if you find
your paper like sprawling out of control
you know where you're feeling like you
might actually write a 20-page paper
that's the time to pull back you know
and it's like well I can I can actually
cut this in half and that can the other
gap can be my second close rating paper
for the class don't feel like you have
to do everything in this one close
reading does that help like I did don't
make a fuss but is it more like
examining what the a character or the
author says or is it more like your
opinion well it's both and when you're
examining what the character of the
author says here's there's a little
intricate character of the author's
making certain claims they're giving
some reasons for those claims you may
have different feelings about those
plans you ought to have reasons for why
you have different feelings or if you
agree with them if you have reasons why
right that's the stuff that's that's the
real meat of it
and a lot of times the reasons are
actually given in the text yeah like I
did promises like but it is like points
what I use like well not all of those
ones right you didn't try to summarize
everything no I like that it's just
something and I'm like what God is a
response and then slowly open like that
that's perfectly fine you're sort of
setting up a classical way of dealing
with this some people say this here's
why they say other people looking at
that same issue saying that's crazy
here's why it's crazy and now I coming
in from the outside you have to have fun
myself to be an expert by summarizing
them bless you now I get to actually get
my own viewpoint on it and here's why I
think this you mean to back up here if
it's common knowledge is what you're
writing about more or less common
knowledge you don't need to document
your Sloan or anything like that you
just you know bring it up if this were
like a research paper that I'd probably
make you have a presence or a source but
my main interest is you you know showing
me you understand what's going on in the
stacks so that's sort of secondary to
that you're using that as an example
more than as as like to back up your arm
right
yeah I'm fine like recording really
evocative cool for actual tax no
separate text there no problem each of
the guys AJ oh yeah when you say when
you're representing their point of view
or when you're saying here's what I
think is dead wrong about it yeah you
know if you can actually point towards
one particular passage that's a good
idea to do yeah
and that's sort of one of the lines of
the question I asked you earlier about
how you backed up your own your own
assertions your own your own right well
since I think we're edges are steering
that way into these strategies let me
get on it though just a few tips for you
you talked about working with blocks and
writing from the tax introducing your
own experiences and pants passions we've
talked about dealing with a crash shows
when you're reading this stuff I think
you guys have noticed this it seems like
it's going all over the place right the
first couple times you read it when
you're this is more about reading
strategies than writing strategies when
you're reading through these ask
yourself why why is he going off in this
direction at this point what does he's
trying to to get it because there's
gonna be some reason why Plato meandered
off in this direction while I Steve
brought up is killing our going on in
self-defense okay or you know the sister
well they have a lot of decorations
don't try to be about making them on a
piece of paper for yourself how the
different parts of the text are very
actually connected with each other how
these different topics and inform each
other that's that's one bit of advice
these kinds of things reconstructing and
analyzing areas this probably goes to
some of the things of you guys well you
know try to get clear for yourself and
it may in fact help you to sort of chart
it out some of you who are more visually
and fine
chart out for yourself what the
structure of the argument is don't be
you know like what I do on the handouts
for you guys yes you know look at the
handouts that they give you I'm just
doing exactly what I you know would like
you to do for yourself not necessarily
with the arguments that I had but with
other herbs and you know you don't have
to be wet is that the handouts that I
give you do you think that you have a
better way to reconstruct the argument
you think I've missed something it's
okay for you to to deviate from because
you're the one who's doing the work it's
your paper as your your interaction with
the text another thing you should try to
do with the arguments try to think
whether there's assumptions to the
arguments that being mentioned in the
text or whether there's assumptions that
these guys are making that you recognize
that maybe they're not recognized and if
you see those if those would actually
have to do with whether it's a good
argument or bad argument that's fair
game for you that's a okay for you to
point out if you think Plato made a
mistake you can tell me Plato made a
mistake you can use that I language just
make sure to give me some sort of reason
some sort of line of reasoning for why
your interpretation should be preferred
and I'm not what you create then again
I'm not looking for anything
earth-shaking because this is their
first encounter with these books
I have something here about working well
with distinctions you notice like
Augustine and Plato and all these people
they make distinctions right you can
make distinctions too you can say well I
think Plato is half right here's the
half I think you got right here's the
half I think you got wrong that's way
more impressive to me
and to any other reader than just saying
Plato's wrong and here's what he's wrong
if you can actually say here's where I
think he actually
you know is on track here's where I
think his argument was good so far
here's where I think it took took the
wrong turn
what are you showing me that you really
understand the material right then you
really understand this argument or this
issue or the distinction that you're
making Leslie
who's there are there distinctions
against that you know he repeats
something to think about
his Plato's Plato actions have knowledge
according to Plato's understanding of
knowledge maybe that's an open question
that's an interesting question then you
could actually break up I would say that
one was sort of like 40 yeah because
that's been such a big issue that you
would open up a lot of cancer awareness
by it by bringing it up but there may be
some points where you actually I don't
want to say are smarter than Plato at
this point or a sister or something like
that but where you have a vantage point
that you can see something they can't
see or didn't put into their text it's
okay for you to bring that up that's
that's an advance that's something
possible I think sometimes when you're
writing teachers taught yourself in the
task you've always had evidence for
every single claim that you're making
does that sound about right they wanted
to mean you away from the habit of just
saying aye aye aye all the time but they
want a little bit to the other extreme
unfortunately so I want you to feel free
to do that
what else yeah we've actually summarized
a lot of these different useful
strategies how often do you guys feel
about like maneuvering to your own stuff
does it make sense to you are there
other questions you have specifically
about using this rubric I'd encourage
you those knew who actually got a nap
done grade yourself with with the rubric
and then we might give you ideas about
to prove this